alright guys here's me again and even
though the game is kind of lagging it's
not all that bad yet so as long as I can
I'll just try to keep this let's play up
now first of all I want to have a path
leading up to the coast - did I yeah
there's good news by the way I inserted
a little bail thing in the bell tower so
that's pretty cool it's moving as well
so um it's all cool but anyway let's
continue with the pass thank you game
for legging that much mm well as soon as
I go away from this extremely dense area
I might get less like at least it does
seem to do that I don't know what kind
of general layout to make him I guess I
could just make it go straight for a
little while and then make it go left or
something right I mean mmm
it's too wide I guess I want any big
paths like these I guess I could make it
go blah blah blah cool yeah that's not
too bad and this is just a general
layout that I'm planning because I do
want quite some path working here yeah I
might change that in the later future
but you might have noticed that I added
these little buildings in the back like
I think real buildings and real theme
parks would happen well because these
are only the front of the buildings of
course and inside the buildings I still
have to put restaurants and they all
shops and stuff so props through the
codemaster who made a CTR of a flying
coaster and gave it to me on skype I
don't know if there's a link to this or
anything I might have to ask him later
on but for now I don't know where to get
this over than just asking him on Skye
personally but you go with a blue color
scheme because I
Lu um this is a bad idea
here let me show you something I want to
I want to place the station first
because I've pretty made a station it's
over here
I made it off-screen sorry for that but
I made it even before I started this
park and I really wanted to use it once
so noticed it knows the time I guess
let's see hmm
I guess this is a good place to build it
or know what's I guess this place would
be better yeah it's more space then I'd
like to place it somewhere in a year
mmm this will do
yeah I think it but I think it looks
really cool so yeah that's the little
station I've got here now that's pretty
coaster inside that's I might have to
change the station covers because
they're sitting on coaster covers and I
need flying coaster covers but I don't
even know if I have those well whatever
let's see what would be a good height I
guess this would be a good height all
right lift Hill let's start with it lift
Hill a little bit of path interaction
here it's always nice and see do these
things need a pre trop I don't think so
but then again I'm not entirely sure
well this is a little bit high anyway
hmm yeah it's too high I don't want an
enormous coaster or anything
yep I can't do that hmm let's see maybe
this would be cool ah
except it's kind of bugging whoa this
element does look awesome
I mean from all angles Wow it's pretty
cool
um but yeah I'm kind of stuck with path
layout here let me just remove that then
let me mess with that later on what I do
want at the moment is some baths in here
leading
I kind of like it and and I could have a
little bit of a Plaza feel in here as
well and have this area being more
densely populated with trees and stuff
but anyway let's continue with the
layout or before I do that's let's check
if it even even even makes this test of
course all right that's cool that's cool
yeah that's pretty good speed it's
pretty good speed that's just slightly
too slow ever so slightly
I don't know about that speed is kind of
bugging me
let's check once again in the POV
position it's a little bit slow but it
doesn't really matter that much in the
POV so I guess I'll leave it like this
because I do like the look of it oh I
could do something cool in here no it's
not really really good I still need a
pretzel loop somewhere I guess
mark is because it's a it's a flying
coaster after all I need a pretzel loop
I could make it go underground but it
has way too much speed for that I could
do something cool with a small overbank
turn no a fall over Bank turn because
already had one of those but something
small ooh oh I like that it's shame II
don't have any curves for these Scott
really there are no large curves for
inverted B&M track I could make it go
around this it's kind of cool
but not really anything amazing hard
hard hard decisions yeah I'm going to
have to try something else
hang on alright I think I've come up
with a pretty cool plan at least I kind
of like it it's a double zero zero over
a path and the second one is just I
don't know whatever you would call it
it's a it's a zero-g roll but it goes
from being inverted but it goes from a
normal you know we call that's basically
it inverts whatever and the first one is
just a regular one and it looks kind of
cool
and I like the whole general look of
this coaster even though it doesn't even
have a looping it's kind of a very
unique but I still like it but the
ending is going to be mayor kind of
boring I guess just a normal and named
with an element like this mmm let's see
I need to get back into the station
about 5h inverted so let's set a
corkscrew because it's a Vietnam anyway
mm-hmm
no I want I need to make this one a
medium curved yeah and then there are
going to be breaks over here and then
there's plenty of space left for a
transfer truck yeah the ending is kind
of meh but the whole idea of there right
you know the end of the ride being next
to a path is kind of cool but other than
that it looks kind of mad when I compare
it to the rest of the ride all right
let's see about speeds it's decent
it's decent little bit slow I might just
make the lift on this bit faster not too
much because I know it doesn't even have
that much of an effect
it's the general layout is just a little
bit too slow and there's no way I'm
going to make the lift so higher than it
is right now because I have to remove
the entire station and bother now this
is all good this is a very nice pace and
into the brick run yeah I do like that
and let's see about the colors of the
cars getting to make this one you know
really I do like the look of it this way
I'll keep it like this and yeah that's
basically this coaster I think I think
I'm going to name it Icarus I know it's
not that original but I really like the
name of it and the way it soars over the
sky and blah blah blah eventually falls
down blah blah blah yeah I do like this
so I'm next episode I'm going to support
this thing I'll probably make a
time-lapse of that and then comes
theming of this area I think it's going
to turn out quite nice so till then